[Music]
hi we are iPhone for all 12 people
strong studio from Krakow Poland -
parole was founded eight years ago and
at the very beginning it was supposed to
deliver a casual mobile games we decided
to go into PC and console market and we
would like to tell you more about our
game see our cleaner we start the
development of serial cleaner in January
2016 and at the very beginning Sarah
greener was supposed to be very
different game
the first idea was to create isometric
puzzle game but then we decided to work
on a fast-paced - the stealth game the
premise of the game is to control a
character who's showing up at crime
scenes and his task is to get rid of the
bodies clean blood pick up evidence
and he always needs to avoid police
officers he's a guy who's very similar
to mr. wolf from pulp fiction and
professional cleaners from John wick
movies and we wanted to see how it can
be translated into game
sir cleaner is said in America in the
70s for a reason because of its style
because of its aesthetics because of the
music and because it was perfect decade
for serial killers in a story mode you
will get to know better
main character Bob Selena he is usually
hired by mob one day he will be called
by a mysterious client who will
drastically change his life you will
have a chance to see where cleaner lives
what he does in his spare time also have
interacts with his mother for example
insured cleaner story mode is the most
important mode in the game but we also
have around 20 challenge modes one of my
favorite challenges it's all time in
which you can play all our levels in a
black and white in drunk mode the vision
is blurred so it's more difficult to see
what's going on super hardcore mode in
which you don't have any vision cones
and a sound indicators and no prompts
so you have to figure it out all by
yourself story mode and challenge modes
in serial cleaner is not everything that
player will get
[Music]
[Music]